let's jump over to another story which
is in a similar vein Oh what and we'll
talk about propaganda check us out this
is Jesse single let's see he's a
journalist he's a good one he writes
he's uh I guess his authoring now former
New York mag and co-host of the bar pod
and he highlights this journalist Zack
Beauchamp who tweeted this I'm sorry but
quote abolish the police seems like a
poorly thought-out idea that's gotten
popular with shocking speed you're here
yep I agree yeah poorly thought out does
Absalom II we've talked about it a lot
and I man I don't even think we've
scratched the surface right of it we've
entertained the intricacies of what that
means right we've entertained the
possibility of shifting responsibilities
of police and shifting responsibilities
into local community watches and
bolstering the Second Amendment to make
it more personal responsibility as a
possibility right but I wouldn't begin
to know what the result of that would be
it's just like I I you know I gotta be
honest I think there is a good
opportunity for figuring out if there's
a way to reassess how our Police
Department's function and we can create
something potentially better I don't
know for sure though and I can tell you
this the reason why he's tweeting about
this is that according to a poll 90% of
American people of color want more
police Wow seriously more more more more
Lewis Wow I was not expecting that
according to the Cato Institute they say
this 9 in 10 black white Hispanic
Americans all oppose reducing the number
of police officers in their community
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I got the
numbers wrong a third say they need more
officers okay 90% say we're good where
we're at yeah and then the third of them
say no we actually need more Wow I'm say
reduce no no
so I guess what is that what does that
leave like less than 10% yeah holy cow
yep if 90 percent say we're good where
we are opposed reducing right that means
you've got 10% that are in favor of
reducing the overwhelming majority is
like we're good we'll keep it we're wet
and what happened to this guy when he
tweeted this they came for him the the
99% the 10% the 9% the people read and
this is dude the hidden tribes more in
common study I gotta pull this up so we
can decide
every time yeah it's constant regressive
activists make up 8% of this country
according to you gov data 8% that's a
the conservative wing makes up 25% in
that crazy the right wing of political
active people is 25% and the left wing
of political active people as 8% Wow but
they control our institutions they have
disproportionate power in media and
that's why you get this this dudes AK I
guess is a journalist he said talk to a
number of people I respect about the
framing of the original tweet and I do
feel like it was a mistake it was far
too dismissive and then I ironically
complained about condescending replies
we all send bad tweets sometimes this
was one of mine bend the knee but it was
a crime this fool sure was an opinion
but it was murder this is this is what's
crazy right now in the New York Times
right this is all is all looping
together the New York Times the Gray
Lady the paper of record has fallen
we've seen the assault on the Gray Lady
to shut to turn it to sjw insanity yeah
and it's and there's been some bad
moments now that's it there was a revolt
160 staffers were you know did a virtual
walk out because Tom cotton wrote an
op-ed saying send in the troops a
position held by 58% of registered
voters yeah and sending in the National
Guard by 71% of net of registered voters
Wow so it's not it's everyone's in favor
well it's not that it's not all
Americans right majority why it seems of
the people who are politically active it
would seem they're mostly in favor of
this and we even have this story right
here where's it right here a plurality
of Democrats would support calling into
the US military to aid police during
protests poll shows so now that we know
that's true you'd think these people
would be alike perhaps we shouldn't get
rid of the police because people
actually like to them you know yet
somehow here is where we are where this
dude is apologizing for what he was
correct about yeah that's that's that's
the craziness the mob so check this out
this guy Connor freighters Dorf said oh
there is an ascendant pressure on
journalists to reify positions that are
held by a minority of the public and a
super majority of journalists if it
succeeds it
will not advance social justice it will
make journalistic institutions that
value social justice less influential
hmm could you imagine what would happen
if Joe Biden came out right now and says
black lives matter it was very important
to me which is why I'm announcing in my
first 100 days I will abolish all police
departments what do you think would
happen
Trump would win Trump could go to sleep
and just just play xbox and eat chunk a
putter commercial be like thank you Joe
I'm under play xbox we got the best
games I've got the new call of duty and
just vote November and I'll see you then
yeah call of duty he goes golfing xbox
Xbox I'm kidding
if Joe Biden says this or in any way
gets close to this position Donald Trump
will be like for my next campaign move
over the next six months I will be
golfing my feet up on my desk I'm gonna
be golfing I'm gonna hang out mar-a-lago
I'm not gonna do any work vote for that
guy if you want to vote for me goodbye
and then he wins 530 electoral votes
yeah how man the the the propaganda
coming from this weird school of thought
thinks they're winning
they might though so James Lindsey who I
reference him now for like the fourth
time today was because he's got these
these threads popping up on all of these
issues that are prominent and he's a
smart dude he's a smart dude yeah he
said basically what they do they
infiltrate an organization until they
have around 15% of it then they either
manufacture or wait for some issue they
can complain about and refuse to let it
go until the company bends the knee and
they hope to either destroy it or
completely take it over if they destroy
it good it's gone one of their opponents
has been wiped out if they take it over
now they can wield its influence and
then he said the New York Times has
something like this the New York Times
will be propped up with nonprofit money
so that these activists can wear it like
some kind of skin suit it's like oh he's
right though that is what scares me man
it's true a lot of people have said that
this woke SJW stuff would never leave
certain smaller communities and college
campuses and how it's taking over the
New York Times we've got it's been
slowly doing it we got to get out there
and show people that you have a thick
skin is
important look at look at the First
Amendment it's like freedom of speech
it's like call me whatever doesn't
matter it's not it's not even about that
it's about political power their
kindness yeah you're right
I I hate I hate saying the communist
word because it's kind of just like a
weird cliche for leftists you hear all
the time yeah but the the fringe
activists that are pushing the stuff
they're literal communists they they
actually are revolutionary communists
and they're looking to in create their
version of a communist utopia you know
it really bothers me the most the most
offensive thing about them is when they
tell me don't you like Star Trek man
we're trying to make a future like Star
Trek no one had to work and they had
free food and all that stuff and I'm
like go home how dare you they had to
work they didn't Star Trek yeah it's
post-scarcity in Star Trek hmm yes the
Star Trek they have replicators so
people who like join the Federation did
things by choice because I wanted to do
things and explore and and and be better
what they do okay
but yeah replicators just made food so
they just do whatever they want we don't
have replicators man we can't just do
that so these people are nuts ultimately
I think they just want to end all of the
good things that we've created it I
don't know why maybe it's like an equal
and opposite reaction thing we've had it
too good for too long and other darkness
is bubbling up yeah or maybe it's like
the light can't exist another dark you
know and the light must defeat it or
maybe sunset sunrise
maybe the Golden Age we had of liberty
and freedom is sunsetting and it can't
go it's a pendulum swing it's it's it's
a it's a revolution it can't change you
know I mean I can't I can't just stay
with it
no you think no way I don't think we can
we you know we can just you know the
saying you know hard times make strong
men strong men make good times I'll say
the whole thing good times make weak men
we can make hard times yeah it's it's
accurate that's the cycle yeah so so
it's not so much that we won't come back
but that we're entering the dark times
no but that's also what what how that
doesn't make sense is because that's
like a full cycle of everyone feeling
the exact same way and that is not the
case there's billions of us on this
planet and we have people that are
refusing to to see
people of color and and segregate it and
be like yes we are different it's like
no no we're all the same we got it we
aren't all weak and not all of us you
know our men you know whatever but it's
it's about a human race see the
backwards what we actually so the the
Civic libertarianism and and you know
magical liberalism types are saying we
recognize that we're not all the same
right but we must we must treat equal
everyone equally under the law which is
the equal equal opportunity right versus
an equal outcome we know it's a class
issue there's a lot of issues out there
but a lot of it is is this class issue
that we're stuck in right I don't not
all of us are going through hard times
but well so but here's the reality men
so people are in different stages of
that that quote so we got to bring
everyone together to be strong and be
able to handle everything but but also
keep in mind you know some stupid people
right illogical maybe which you know not
everyone I know some dumb people okay
like okay like you you'd be like like
low IQ you mean yeah all right in a
unable to actually function and do a job
these people are unlikely to become
super wealthy okay because they don't
understand how to become super wealthy
so you're saying there will always be a
class of people that are dumb no I think
I'm saying there I think some people are
dumb some people are smart humans have
variability within their development
okay and I think also that there are
just environmental factors we can't
control which will result in some people
having certain abilities and some not
I'm not gonna complain the NBA is all a
bunch of 7-foot tall you know dudes I'm
not seven feet tall I don't want to play
in the NBA I got no egg it's not my
dream I guess and if you really want to
work hard for it you can probably figure
it out how do i how to get there then
everybody can okay not everybody can do
every single job so the fact is these
people believe that we are all the same
literally remind women are the same
everyone's the same you know this is
critical it wasn't called like a
critical gender theory then that the
only reason women are weaker than men is
because they're trained from a young age
not to engage in the same behaviors but
if that women did sport they'd be just
as strong and that's not
no that's not right so men on average
will always have more muscle mass yeah
and Men a female on average will always
have less muscle mass and more fat and
it's for different reasons I suppose you
can be one of these people that wants to
manufacture some kind of equality but it
can never be it can never be imagined if
we invented something that turned that
guaranteed genetic engineer guaranteed
everybody was the same hairless olive
skin colored type person men and women
were of equal height and strength guess
what women still have the babies that
means they have to dedicate time and
energy to creating and and and and
giving birth to that baby mm-hmm and
that means that even if it's only like
you know that that that several days or
whatever in which they're going to the
hospital doing with labor and and giving
birth several days where they're not
working that will still confer an
advantage to the males who can spend
that time investing and working
theoretically you can you can pass a law
then where it's like the man must be in
the hospital with women at all times and
sure and try and force humans to be the
same mmm we're not robots though we're
not the model you know a 93 humanoid
we're all individuals that develop with
variability that's true because of that
there's gonna be class so what do we
want to do we want to make sure that
everybody has a chance has the same
chance as everybody else
yeah and that if you choose you can
succeed maybe you won't you're not gonna
be Jeff Bezos man you know why there's
one there's this how many billionaires
you know soon-to-be trillionaire like
one or two yeah out of the billions man
it's it's not gonna be you you know and
it doesn't mean it's a bad thing isn't
mean you're better or worse it just
means this out life is these people who
are taking over the New York Times want
to create a world where we're all gray
blobs they're identical in every single
way it is not possible we're not deal
we're all different yep if you zoom out
far enough we look the same
yeah the more you zoom in the more
uniquely become well mentally physically
we're all the same
I mean yeah we differ but we're we're
all we all believe the same color right
really what I'm trying to say we're all
humans right we're all we all have the
same base functions of what makes us
work brains kidneys hearts livers
the variability in intelligence but so
that my understanding of current biology
and psychology is that the variability
in intelligence and everything is
actually relatively low but don't you
think that would that would change if we
if we really I don't know the answers
but if we elevate everybody to a more of
a base level not I'm not saying get rid
of capitalism or you know I don't you
know but if we bring it up so that that
baseline the average is significantly
higher what's the average IQ 100 100 is
the average IQ that's what's what so
yeah right so say we eliminate it and
give everyone everyone has that chance
right - so a hundred years go by don't
you think the average IQ of humanity is
gonna be significantly higher well so
the way IQ works as it tracks the
average so 100 is baseline okay so we do
generally about 145 is genius once
you're past that you're officially a
genius your brain relative to everybody
else functions I thought it is literally
1/4 I don't I don't I don't think IQ is
actually a really good measure of how
you're gonna okay I mean it's like it
isn't exactly the player making yeah
okay I do not think you can create a
world where everyone starts at there's
there's no way to create a world where
the starting line is equal for every
single person well I'm not I'm not even
saying that it's gonna be equal for
everybody you know because families can
you know travel their money down you
know whatever any of the different
examples there but if everyone has a
chance you know if we get rid of the
poor you know I think I think there's I
gotta believe that there's a poor
where's a poor person today uh-huh is
wealthier than John Rockefeller was 100
usik okay I mean technically it's not
true but the point is no it's definitely
not true no but what I mean is the
average person is considered extreme
poverty by today's standards okay for
the entire planet like okay the poor
people in this country of air
conditioning have refrigerators
refrigerator everyone's got flat-screen
TV in a cell phone you can buy a cell
phone for 20 bucks get a data plan
unlimited everything 20 bucks on
t-mobile okay
that is wealth that means somebody in a
you know even in impoverished areas in
in the middle of nowhere can look up how
to farm so poverty will always exist
because poverty is relative that's a
good point so you're always gonna have
look I work every single day and the I
only have two half days off where I only
work a full shift in the morning so I
work a full shift then we do this show
at night yeah I don't have to and other
people choose not to because of that I'm
better off than they are because of that
my kids will have advantages yeah should
we take away all of that extra money
I've made by my choice if you do that
then why would I bother doing this show
well I think even like say you know
Trump is bringing jobs back here where
the factories are all returning people
are gonna lose their you know big huge
profits because they're gonna have to
pay minimum minimum wage to their
employees people are gonna get much
better jobs there's gonna be a lot more
jobs available if that's the case so
then all of a sudden all these factories
that we've lost now people can actually
work so there's jobs everywhere
all across the country yep this is like
that it's like I want the people who are
poor to have an opportunity to write be
able to have it yes exactly like as I
said that's like I don't have the answer
but it's luck I want to find the answer
I want to move towards the answer
instead of just everyone's just throwing
insults at each other bribing blaming
and that's this blame game no one wants
to actually have a conversation about it
we're to move forward
yeah that's it's really aggravating me
and you try and talk to him and they
just get mad at you because they're
looking for the other they're like no no
I don't want to figure this out I just
want to scream my ideology at you until
you agree with me if we bring back all
these jobs to United States and reopen
these factories yeah two things are
gonna happen people in China are gonna
lose jobs because those are the jobs
they used to have okay and now they're
gonna become poorer so you can say I'm
in favor of helping America first and I
get it some people argue it's better off
helping these foreign countries to lift
everybody up and that means American
sacrifice I got the idea the other thing
that will happen is the guy who started
that factory to bring those jobs back
will become rich and you will always
have
top tier and the bottom the Communists
want to get rid of all that but they
don't understand why that doesn't work
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you